لا يصمت السلاح في السودان اشتباكات
متقطعه تتوسع رقعتها الجغرافيه في بعض
ولايات البلاد ليبقى الوضع في دارفور
وكوردوفان متوترا مع قتال في عدد من مدن
هذه الولايات من دارفور غرب البلاد
البدايه حيث يقول الجيش انه رصد تعزيزات
وارتالا عسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع قادمه
من غرب السودان باتجاه الخرطوم وتعتبر
ولايات دارفور الخمس مع قيل قوه للدعم
السريع ففي تلك الولايات خاضت قوات الدعم
السريع قتالا غير تقليدي على مدى عقدين
تقريبا اما الوضع وسط البلاد في كردفان
فيبقى متغيرا في منطقه واد باندا بولايه
غرب كردفان استهدف الجيش مواقع للدعم
السريع واعلنت الحكومه حاله طوارئ وحظرا
للتجوال في الولايه
الاعلان هذا على ما يبدو يرمي الى قطع
الطريق على اي امدادات بالمقاتلين والسلاح
لقوه الدعم السريع قد تستخدم من دارفور
فلقوات الدعم السريع تمركز واضح في جنوب
وشمال وغرب كردفان بالانتقال الى ولايه
البحر الاحمر شرقا يبقى الوضع فيها حذرا
ويمسك الجيش بمفاصل الامور فيها فالولايه
تشكل جزءا من الساحر الرئيس في السودان
وخاصه ان عاصمه الولايه بورسودان تستضيف
الميناء الاهم التي تحول الى مرتكز في
عمليات اجلاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه
والرعايه الاجانب اما الولايات الشرقيه
كسل والجدارف والنيل الازرق في الجنوب
الشرقي والتي تشكل منفذا اساسيا بمسار
النازحين واللاجئين فتبقى في عهده الجيش
وتشهد هدوءا وان كان حذرا
[موسيقى]